i've been talking about abolishing the
police now for the past i guess a couple
of months
but and michael malus has been cheering
for it on twitter but
it's not for the same reason for the
most part
you know what so so michael said when we
had alex jones on the show
he said that it's his constitutional
right to keep and bear arm to defend
himself
and every single cop in new york city
would arrest him if he tried to uphold
his own rights and that's why he said
every single cop was was bad and alex
was like no you can't say that that's
wrong
and only michael malus can make alex
jones the moderate right right right and
that's
but so so i'm actually i actually do
think we need police the problem is we
they shouldn't be following uh in
unconstitutional orders
enforcing illegal laws or taking illegal
action but now the main reason
because i've had people message me
saying tim you're wrong about abolishing
the police well hold on
have you been paying attention to what's
going on what story did we just cover
just in
the previous in the last segment
portland antifa
in blackout gear which they've been
doing the whole time now with rifles
stopping vehicles smashing out their
windows attacking pedestrians and
regular folk
and when a guy tries to get through and
draws on them because they drew on him
already
they knock him down to take his gun
where the cops the cops can't stop
antifa
in portland the more the majority of
people who were arrested even on felony
charges
even people who confessed to attacking
cops
had their charges dropped but guess what
the fbi is hunting down each and every
single conservative
in new york city when the proud boys
fought fought antifa those proud boys
are now in prison
the system is broken it's corrupted we
are watching all of this happen every
day
and the cops may be neutral arbiters
it's a sorting algorithm
where they are they are funneling people
on left and right into a justice system
that is
only punishing the right and moderates
and those who are standing up for small
businesses
i i assure you if you live in the in the
portland area
and these these groups with guns come
out if you
even try to defend yourself you will get
locked up we've already seen it happen
one guy
who drew on these black lives matter
protesters he got charged i think
he got a felony or something he had a
felony charge and he was
legally bearing his arm which is allowed
to do and there was a group a raucous
group
which is known to have been violent in
protest and he drew on them
you could argue the whole thing all day
and night but a felony charge so here's
what's going to happen
conservatives have consistently defended
the cops and i understand why
because cops do a tough job but then we
started seeing cops
shut down small businesses arrest small
business owners and then conservatives
start saying
nah i'm done with this and throwing the
thin blue line flag in the dirt and
stomping on it
now it's starting to come back to
defending cops again and i'm like do you
realize
you're the target in new york city it's
like what 20 percent conservative it's
like
very very few conservatives when antifa
goes around smashing up windows these
people aren't going to go to jail
when you go and in any way defend
yourself or defy
these restrictions they will lock you up
in two seconds it was the funniest thing
when that salon owner in in texas i
think it was
she got arrested for opening her salon
while they were letting the criminals
out of the jail
they were saying we can't have criminals
in jail because of covet but she can
and they they uh were saying it was uh
dangerous for kovid to
open your salon but we will take you and
put you in jail where there's this
massive covet outbreak
absolutely letting people out but and
that's that's inhumane to put someone
into a
situation yeah well i mean it's inhumane
to put a human being in a cage for the
crime of opening their business period
but
particularly in a patent while letting
the criminals out have you heard the
term anarcho-tyranny
before because that's what this is
describing so the idea of
anarcho-tyranny
is the idea that you have the worst of
both worlds right right you have the
worst of anarchism
and the worst of tyranny so there are
incredibly
rigid rules that you will be just
destroyed for violating i mean if you
get something wrong on your tax form
you will go you know to jail for this if
you do what you know there's all of
these different laws that you can be
busted for for any different
number of felonies that you don't even
know about like we all commit like five
felonies a day without even knowing it
right but then at the same
sense there's the worst sense of anarchy
for people so
you get your car stolen and a cop comes
up to you and goes well that sure does
suck i can fill out a form and then
we'll see you later but if you defend
yourself with
you know a weapon then you're gonna go
to jail and that's what we're seeing
more and more right
we're seeing the fact that this has been
going on in san francisco and los
angeles and all these places where if
someone comes in and steals from your
store
we're not really going to prosecute them
but if you pull a gun on them while
they're stealing from their store you
might go to jail for a decade so this is
the this is the world that we're living
in more and more now
and i think that conservatives are
starting to realize
that they are the enemy group so for you
for you to be defending the enforcers of
the state which let's get real that's
what cops are
for you to be defending them when you're
the enemy group
is uh to borrow a word that some on the
right like to use
the ultimate in cockatry we're at a
point now where
we're we've been watching this for a
year the salon owner
they they open the jails and release the
criminals
and then put the small business owner in
the jail i mean that's that's tyranny so
i made that point
if this continues conservatives will be
less less able to vote because
they're being charged with felonies not
even conservatives like moderates who
defend themselves are going to get
felony charges
can't vote sorry in many states i mean
the left might actually give them their
right to vote back
in a long enough period of time it will
just detriment the right
and it will scare everyone into being
clearly we don't want to be with
whatever that is
i'll just do what the left says but hold
on what if at this point we said alright
how about this no cops
then what happens well you can keep and
bear arms now
you can defend yourself and you can
defend yourself
oh this would be cleaned up in a second
believe me all these
riots you don't need trump to send in
the federal
goons or anything like that if you just
said all it takes and there were a
couple like local sheriffs who did this
during the riots and basically cleaned
up their whole
town yeah if you just said hey guess
what we believe in the second amendment
here
and if you go and and if there was
actually the
the state behind you on this and you
said if you go and violate someone's uh
private property and they have a gun we
are not prosecuting them for defending
themselves
this thing would be cleaned up but by
the way can i just make one more point
to what you were saying before
what were the few exceptions for the
people who were actually prosecuted
uh during all of these governments the
government buildings that were
that were attacked right so what is the
clear message from the government there
how disgusting is this
stay away from our property you go ahead
and you vandalize any of the private
property you want to
you go terrorize a shoe store owner go
terrorize a bodega
no problem you stay away from the state
house and you'll be just
conservatives got to get on board with
abolishing the police and not
every single instance small towns are
probably fine
but the best example is in milwaukee
when black lives matter i think was
milwaukee they showed up to a guy's
house right
they were protesting in front of his
house one of the guys who organized this
had previously been to another mob
gathering that set fire to someone's
home
so all these people are outside
screaming this guy pulls up his shotgun
and points it out the window
the window's closed but he points it you
know visibly at the window when the
police show up
black lives matter is clapping and
cheering and celebrating as the cops go
into this man's home and arrest him
whoa for what now maybe you shouldn't
have pointed the gun directly at them
but like i said these one the guy who
organizes had previously organized
another rally where they set fire to a
woman's home
they said like twice cops came out put
it out they set fire to it again
so this guy's like i'm gonna show them
i'm armed and you can make an argument
whether he should or shouldn't have done
that
i believe people have a right to keep
and bear arms and if you're on your
property and people are encroaching on
your property and threatening you
it was he didn't even fire a shot it was
a warning but here's the point
the cops gleefully arrested him
the worst point black lives matter
celebrated that means
you think people have been saying they
want they want to abolish the police
they can federalize it they want to
abolish police to get their awoken
forces in
they don't really want to abolish the
police they want to exert pressure until
the police start doing whatever they
want out of fear of losing their jobs
yeah well why do you think they did such
a 180 on abolish the police
i mean as soon as the implications of
that started coming out they were like
well abolish the police doesn't really
mean abolishing
or defund the people that's the
democrats no what i mean is the left
comes out and says abolish the police
and the cop goes i don't want to lose my
job
well then you better arrest the
conservative you got it anything you say
please i'm so i'm begging you please
well look i mean if you're somebody
who's if you are a right-winger
or a conservative just think through the
implications of actually defunding the
police and what that would mean
well it's like like you said well
there's nobody's going to arrest you for
any type of gun violation so gun rights
are now absolute
they're not going to be able to enforce
these like stupid regulations on your
business who's going to be the tax
collectors who's going to do all of this
it actually leads to a much smaller
government
world which would be a much better
situation
and take personal response i will say
this too it also uh
takes away what are some of the
legitimate criticisms of people on the
left which i'm not saying is like the
violent rioters but there are some
people on the left who make a legitimate
point that there are cops
who go around and harass people in the
these high crime neighborhoods
now i'm not saying that there aren't
legitimate criminals in those
neighborhoods who deserve to be harassed
but there's also let's get real there's
a lot of kids who walk around who just
look like the suspect that they're
trying to go after in these
neighborhoods who get harassed
and let them also let them also not be
harassed anymore
also but you know the whole war on guns
like the whole all the whole gun control
regime i mean the real
victims of it not saying it's the
exclusive victims
but the the most likely victims of it
are people who live in these high crime
neighborhoods who are minorities for the
most part
who are who have guns usually to protect
themselves and they get charged and they
get changed
we got guys we have uh tons of people in
this country
disproportionately black and brown
people who are sitting in cages for
decades for the crime of owning
a gun not doing anything to anyone with
that gun
just having a gun the prohibition on
guns has been just as disastrous as the
prohibition on
drugs and we should end all of them i
think the party of personal
responsibility
should start taking more of it because
you know look i get it
maybe there's this vision of like an old
timey era when officer friendly was
there to protect your community
now we're at a point where the justice
system is basically corrupted
extremely wealthy leftists started
funding district attorneys races putting
in far-left das people like kim fox
after jesse smallett's whole ridiculous
you know maga country garbage kim fox
lets him go
this guy it was so obvious this is what
happens the justice system is completely
corrupt
but i gotta stress man the proud boys in
new york city
four years in prison yeah if the proud
boys want to get in a fight with antifa
because anthony's been threatening and
harassing them
then maybe you don't want police to be
there to arrest you and put you in
prison afterwards
when you decide that you are going to
confront the problem in the way you
think is
is appropriate now look i don't think
fighting is appropriate i don't think
anybody should be fighting antifa or the
proud boys
but if antifa wants to show up to
someone's event and instigate fights
okay then there's a thing called mutual
combat okay maybe that's what we need
the problem is
in new york you can't have guns you
can't protect yourself if you
if you even consider it they will lock
you up
the problem is that the way i described
it recently is imagine you're at a
blackjack table at a casino
and it's it's a right-wing guy and the
left-wing guy
the left-wing guy is counting cards and
you're sitting there going like he keeps
winning
he's winning like he's look how much
money he's got i keep losing
because the house always wins the the
dealer isn't playing favorites
it's just that they're gaming the system
and the house is gaming you
that's where we're currently at with
conservatives defending cops
it's going to keep going after small
businesses antifa is going to
walk around the street with rifles now
hold on they're allowed to do that
you can walk around with a gun
constitutional right keep and bear arms
but they smash out windows they attack
pedestrians and then draw down
on some dude who's driving his truck
through the area guess when no charges
guess when police first started
in america it was the uh late 1600s
early 1700s yeah
1636 so it was like night watch groups
that would report to like a constable
well it was initially we had local
militias
some states i think there were like two
states set up slave patrols
from that the left has tried arguing
that the origin of all police was slave
patrols
the idea of centralized law enforcement
was actually imported from some european
countries i think was like amsterdam or
something
and so eventually people started saying
maybe instead of having these ever
escalating conflicts between neighbors
and the militia
we just create neutral arbiters who will
come down make the arrest and the courts
can deal with it
we're at a point now where that that i
think that's a great idea
however in these blue states people
don't care about your rights and believe
they have a right to vote away your
rights
so they'll say like i don't care the
second amendment says i think we can
just decree your right doesn't exist
the constitution was supposed to stop
that apparently it doesn't now you have
conservatives who live in these places
who are surrounded by cops who would
gladly enforce illegal actions like bill
de blasio's ridiculous painting or
arrest
you for exercising your god-given rights
the state doesn't give them to you the
government doesn't god did that's in the
constitution
the thing that's so infuriating to me is
that we've
watched um let's just say just in the
21st century not going back you know the
whole history of policing but just in
the 21st century
i mean the we have the most militarized
police force
in the world i mean well i'm just saying
there's really nothing left there's
really no country
out there that has as many swat units
has as much military gear and their
police officers
when i say this i mean but is that
because we're a big country i don't
think that's a fair
no i mean i think even per capita even
our department of education has a swat
team the epa
has a swat team i mean we have like we
have a police force
look it up i promise you we have a
police force that's just
unlike anything else the nypd i think is
in the top
20 biggest armies in the world like it's
not just that we're a big country i mean
there's a lot more to it than that and a
lot of it is right
up the department of education as a swat
team oh yeah no the department of
education all right you got me there
that's a weird one so i'm saying like
and we have all of this
and if it was ever justified you'd be
like well when there's mass riots
this militarized police will make sure
to stop it and then when there are the
mass riots
they do nothing and then i mean what is
i think we have 50
000 swat raids on average a year or
something like that i mean it's
something crazy and you'll have
swat raids over like
alleged drug possessions sometimes they
get the wrong house and just shoot your
dog or whatever they've shot kids before
it's like swot ray you know if you were
to think about it in theory and we were
just talking about it like when is it
appropriate
to have a swat raid you'd probably be
like i don't know like a hostage
situation
when someone's about to kill someone
else maybe not it's like i think he's
got a no-no plant
in his drawer and they so we have this
this is what i mean by the anarcho
tyranny
we have the worst to go after the former
president's
lawyer right right exactly or roger
stone or something like that so we have
the worst of a police state
without any of even the benefits of it
like they'll protect your property if
there's a riot
so i mean you know do you remember the
story there was some guy i can't
remember exactly what it was so maybe
i'm getting a little bit wrong factor me
on this one
he put grow lamps in a house he like
rented a house he put grow lamps in it
with
like ficus or some stupid houseplant and
then he
set up cameras and just waited and then
a swat team raided the house
and he was like what are you doing in my
like what's going on they jump out with
cameras they're filming all the cops and
they're like what are you doing
and they apparently tried using grow
lamps as justification that they were
doing a drug raid
wow because they they were detecting the
energy consumption yeah they could see
the energy consumption and so they made
an assumption about what's going on in
the house
and i bet you none of those cops went to
jail no but the guy like put on the
internet and he was like
sure and embarrass them but you know if
we had any type of like
just society going here wouldn't you be
like well okay i mean
you just committed a crime right you
broke into somebody's house like
any of us would go to jail if we did
that but they don't so and and the other
thing that i got to say
is that you know i understand and i
agree with a lot of what you're saying
like and and
there is like a lot of these left-wing
uh um
you know cities and states do have these
problems
but i gotta say i find something not
maybe kind of funny in a dark way but
certainly ironic
that now joe biden is turning the war on
terror
inward and the target is right wingers
and even liz cheney
is like championing this and i i guess
i'm just old enough to remember
that it was the right wingers who
supported george w
bush who championed this whole war on
twitter
these are not the same and mocked a lot
of them
he switched no no i'm not just talking
he's a democrat now i'm not an arms
dealer
the republican party is not on board
with that let's change i'm not
i'm not talking about just the
republican party or the ones who went
over to the democratic party i'm saying
that
right wingers in america voted
for dick cheney and george w bush and
they
mocked i'm not saying all of them but a
large enough percentage of them
boxed 20 years ago so you're right and
now they're about now the chickens have
come home to roost
no you know you're talking about 38 year
olds who didn't vote for that who are
now finding themselves conservatives or
republican beings
they are that's right they are paying
for the sins of the right wingers who
came before absolutely
who who you know
i don't care if it's democrat republican
we're paying for the penalties of their
failures
going back so much of the problems with
this country and don't get me wrong i
think you can go back to woodrow wilson
and pretty much blame everything on him
but all of it i mean yes and i believe
that
all woodrow wilson's fault all woodrow
wilson's fault
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time